hello Arnold my name is Joe wheeler how  would you like to be the face of  bodybuilding I am training you to be the  best in the world are your nuts are you  what you do not realize is all these men  wants is to compete against the very  best three two copycats from Canada huh  maybe you should be taken seriously you  do create strong competitors mr. Howe  Curtin but to create an impeccable man  it takes dignity and grace qualities you  know nothing about good luck  this is just the beginning you saw just  how well I met this work you relentless  joke on mine no your problem is you have  to man it up intensifies  what's do this  [Music]  deciding right  kid welcome to the big time we're the  biggest and the best joke  you won't  you